and while everyone's sitting down I will
say we I'm not gonna talk about it here
but we published an article in science
magazine you know the biggest climate
change we have is the annual cycle and
we looked hard at the annual cycle and
the performance of climate models and
none of the climate models that have a
climate sensitivity of less than three
we're able to come close well we could
rule them all out as being candidates
for the real world in terms of climate
sensitivity it doesn't mean that you
can't construct a model with the climate
sensitivity of less than three that
might satisfy the constraints of the
annual cycle but at the current time
none of the syma three models or the
cyma five models with a climate
sensitivity of less than three can
simulate the annual cycle with
sufficient integrity to be candidates
for the real world all right with a
whole lot of economists here I had to
talk a little bit about the real system
alright so we're going to talk a little
bit about especially the this period
here after 1970 so let's begin so this
is this is the record there's the
warmest years over there and this is the
record since 1970 after about 1970 is
when global warming really kicked in in
the sense that the the temperature
perturbations are outside of the bounds
of natural variability and you can fit a
straight line to this it's actually a
pretty good fit as it turns out there's
some scatter about this as there is
about the overall when you look at the
overall record and you can see the
biggest departure is actually 1998 which
was the big El Nino year all right and
so what a deniers do they take 1998 and
they put a curve like this on it say oh
look it's cooling of course it's really
warming if you take that period after
1998 and fit a straight line to it it
actually indicates that it's warming and
by the way I'm using the NOAA record
here rather than the Hadley crew record
so it's got a somewhat better depiction
of the polar region and you can also
look at this period and say has it
happened before and
my gosh looks pretty similar anyway
Steve Steve Schwartz gave me a nice
introduction on this a lot of our work
in recent times have been trying to
understand the energy flows through the
climate system and so this does relate
to climate change and to some extent to
climate sensitivity and radiative
forcing and under no climate change the
absorbed solar radiation which is the
net here between the reflected and the
incoming and the outgoing long-wave
radiation have to be in balance in some
sense I won't say anything at the moment
about timescales
and with climate change we have increase
in greenhouse gases which reduces the
outgoing long-wave radiation and so
there's a net imbalance at the top of
the atmosphere which is pretty well
reflected at the surface because the
atmosphere has very little heat capacity
and so this is the net imbalance in the
in the global energy so how do we
measure the the net imbalance in the
climate system from a standpoint of
energy we now have direct measurements
from space this is from the series
instrument of the absorb solar radiation
the outgoing long-wave radiation in the
net we can also take an inventory of
where all of the energy has gone and so
we've been doing and trying to do that
and we can also use climate models with
specified forcings
there is another way but I won't mention
it because it's not useful at the
current time so the commentary on this
is that the first method is not accurate
enough in an absolute sense but it's
it's supposed to be good for relative
changes to change from month to month
from year to year over the since 2000
we've got the record so over the 13 or
14 years that we've got the record so
this is the only way we can really do
the absolute values I've said that it's
best here but you know we wrote a paper
that was published in science saying
that when we do this kind of thing there
seems to be some energy missing and
there are problems over time because the
observing system keeps changing
and number three depends on well how
good is the climate model and
secondly how good are the forcings and
so we've touched on that from a
different from a different standpoint
here with regard more to climate
sensitivity so if we have more energy
coming into the climate system where
does this energy go well it does warm
the land in the atmosphere which is
really what we're talking about when
we're dealing with climate sensitivity
we're talking about the surface global
mean surface temperature record a lot of
the energy goes into the ocean which
expands the ocean and raised a sea level
a lot of it goes well some of it goes
into melting land ice Greenland is
melting glaciers are melting which also
raise a sea level because more water
goes into the ocean
it melts Arctic sea ice and so on and
and the subsequent water has to warm up
it also goes into changing the water
cycle it can evaporate moisture causing
changes and rainstorms changing the
cloudiness therefore changing the albedo
of the planet and so this can also then
alter the net radiation coming into the
system by altering the absorb solar
radiation over 90% of the energy however
goes into the ocean this has already
been mentioned so looking at one method
now looking at ccsm for which it was
commented before is actually a pretty
good model and here we have run the
model eight times - with perturbations
to it and what I'm showing here is the
ensemble average for the from 1850 on
and this last part this part here is
just blowing up down the bottom so if
you want to see a blow up you can just
look down the bottom it's identical and
here you can see these big dips in this
record are all due to volcanic eruptions
that have been put in at the time or
close to the time when they were
observed and then the this is one
standard deviation about the ensemble
average and that value in terms of
monthly values is actually 0.62 watts
per square meter for the standard
deviation
so that's the surprising to me
surprisingly large value from the model
and it turns out this is quite
consistent with the series data also and
so there's quite a lot of fluctuations
in this energy imbalance from one month
to the next and this is then caused
mostly by changes in cloudiness so we
have a big storm it generates a lot of
cloud that blocks the Sun but you know
it's gone the next few weeks and the
system recovers and a lot of that
averages out I've got here also the 12
month running mean this is not reduced
by the square root of 12 which is what
you would expect if it's entirely random
because as I will show you we also have
inter-annual variability associated with
El Nino the Cadle variability and so on
so his the values for the 12 month
running mean I'm actually showing the 8
ensemble members here and in fact as you
can see they all pretty well fit within
the one standard deviation monthly
values then you can see the fluctuations
in here so this is natural variability
that is occurring within this model from
one run to the next the El Ninos occur
at different times they're not
constrained and then as I say this is
the value for the 12-month running mean
value looking at this overall you'll see
that the net energy imbalance is close
to zero up til around
sorry 1960 oh there abouts and then the
energy imbalance increases and you've
got these sharp volcanic eruptions that
are included in here these are just the
major ones there's a lot missing here
there's an overall increase in aerosols
which is included in this in this record
as well but it's highly idealized the
way in which the volcanoes have been put
in here are somewhat idealized as well
so in terms of the model forcings
it's somewhat idealized note the values
as we come to the end it's around an
energy imbalance of 0.9 0.9 watts per
square meter
all right now here's the pun the same
model identical model in fact the only
perturbations were different months
different days of the week we were used
to initialize the atmospheric and then
it just developed in a chaotic fashion
so there were not even big perturbations
that were put in I've worked with
Magdalena balmaceda who probably at ICI
MWF who probably have the best ocean
data assimilation system that exists at
the moment it's not perfect but
nonetheless it does assimilate all of
the available data all of the ocean data
from Argo floats the surface information
from sea surface temperatures the
surface fluxes the winds and all of the
sea level information at which after
1992 which is from altimeters from space
and this is the record of the ocean heat
content from the ECMWF reanalysis in 10
to the 22 joules this is the top 300
meters here this is actually an ensemble
system also by the way there are five
members here which reflect uncertainties
and things like the surface fluxes and
various things this is the top 700
meters and the 0 here is for the first I
think five years or something like that
eight years I'm back here and then this
is down to the bottom of the ocean so
here you do see this leveling off in
particular after about 2003 in the top
300 meters which is more reflective of
what's happened at the surface in some
ways but when you go to the bottom of
the ocean you do not see this leveling
off to anything like the same extent but
this is not a very simple curve back in
here the observing system is really poor
prior to 1970 and I don't know whether
you should pay any attention to this
back in here at all except but I'm going
to show you something here in just a
minute and there's quite a bit of
character to this and this is really for
the first time we haven't seen this in
ocean
temperature records that have been
reconstructed before to anything like
the extent that we're showing here and
what I want to highlight here is the
fact that for the first time in an ocean
heat content record we're actually
seeing signatures of the three major
volcanic eruptions that have occurred in
this period and so there's a sharp
cooling here with a gong and with LG
chang with Pinatubo and i've also
identified something interesting in here
in in 1997-98 you can see that actually
continues on this is an arbitrary length
of time I've got here for for some time
and there was a huge cooldown of the
ocean
both the tropical Pacific and in fact
the global ocean following that
particular El Nino event 1998 was the
warmest year in the 20th century it was
a time when the ocean was cooling the
energy imbalance at the top of the
atmosphere was negative so there's some
rules there's some things associated
with this we've actually got the warmest
year on record at a time when the planet
is actually cooling because the heat is
coming out of the ocean and contributing
to the warmth at the surface now it
turns out this happens on de kado
timescales as well and it happens also
always in association with El Nino
events so this is some lessons in some
ways for interpreting what we're going
to be talking about here so here's the
I'm just looking now after 1980 this is
down to seven hundred meters this is the
record we were just looking at and the
thing I really want to do is to convert
this into rates of change this is not a
trivial not an easy thing to do and if
you do this with most of the ocean heat
content records that exist from other
sources you will find that they're all
over the place with incredible amounts
of noise it's documented in a paper
which we've got here but these are
twelve months running means you can see
now a bit more what's happening with
regard to these perturbations that are
indicating the uncertainty with with
these five ensemble members so
so here's the actual rates of change
that you can see is quite variable over
this over this record through here this
is what it looks like for the total
depth now put it behind here and in fact
through here you can't see much
difference and then after about 1998 you
can see the purple a little bit higher
than the blue and in fact the difference
the average difference in the 2000s is
0.21 watts per square meter going to the
full depth versus the top 700 meters so
0.21 watts per square meter is going
into the deeper part of the ocean now
that's actually important but it's
really only after 1998 the other things
on here these are the times of the
volcano is this volcano if you look
closely at this record this drop
actually occurs in March of 1982 what
we're doing looking at is that with the
12 month running mean is we actually
look ahead so that it starts to drop you
know five months ahead of that
particular date so that's what you're
actually seeing there but these are
actually very reasonable numbers as it
turns out so I'll show you that right
now
so what what happens if we put these
together now I've got in the background
here
the ensemble values and the one standard
deviation from the model along with
these values for the entire record with
five ensemble members of the socha heat
content put together so firstly let's
look at the volcanoes his Mount Hagen
this given the state of the observing
system at that time this is pretty
remarkable agreement I think between
these two things a lot of this must be
coming from the sea surface temperature
record I suspect his his Pinatubo again
you know I think you would expect to see
that it's slightly broader so it doesn't
quite have the magnitude but I think
this is actually excellent agreement
from from what you would expect now here
for LG Chong there's a difference and it
turns out using this we were able to go
back at the record and we saw that the
way they put LG
Shawn into the model they had an
idealized function attached to it and it
has a delay of about six months in terms
of when the peak occurred in the model
and when it occurred in nature and it
actually shows up here as a delay and I
mean there's some interesting things
going on here because it turns out in
association with all of these there were
all Nino events that caused
complications in fact you can see this
goes way up very quickly and what I've
marked on here also are all of the El
Nino events and so if you look carefully
on here with the El Nino events at the
end of the El Nino events you see a
cooling in fact with 99 is 90 97 98 so
here's this big cooling that's going on
through here
and so El Nino events are causing a lot
of the variability now what about the
overall agreement
I don't know and in here these values in
the ocean are a bit higher than we're
expecting based on the model here
they're definitely lower this is
Pinatubo and and the 97-98 El Nino event
I say you know this given this is plus
or minus one standard deviation perhaps
this is not too bad let's see something
this is the actual values of the aerosol
optical depth so these are volcanoes and
things which are not included in the
model small volcanoes and things like
that and notice there's a there's a peak
in here and there's a sharp dip actually
occurs in the ocean heat content wonder
whether those two things are related or
whether it's just a consequence of the
El Nino event there's some extra things
that are worth exploring there so anyway
the comment my comment on this is that
there's well not unreasonable agreement
but maybe the model doesn't have quite
enough variability some of it might be
because there's missing forcings
the four things are not quite accurate
the the fluctuations from year to year
are not accurate but you know maybe it's
it's not too bad anyway now looking at
the more recent period what I'm showing
you now is the series record along with
some arrow bars on it and an extra arrow
bar with the dotted curve which relates
to the stability of the overall orbit to
some extent and here the energy
imbalance is sort of set to 0.8 watts
per square meter which is designed to
fit with the ocean heat content so the
ocean heat content from RS 4 is is also
plotted on here and you can see in this
earlier part here it's a bit higher than
the series values and in the latter part
it's a bit lower and then I've got some
other values here which are from this is
from our go this is care let's have a
look down here Kareena von Schuch Minh
is estimate for based upon Argo
so neither of these have anything in the
Arctic for instance or and also nothing
in Indonesia or in marginal seas and
they are offering quite good support for
the rs4 rs4 probably also doesn't have
enough in the Arctic going on I would
say that it's not a region that's been a
major region of attention so there are
there's other information I could show
you another figure which only goes down
to 700 meters we've got a whole bunch of
other ocean analyses that tend to
support certainly this these high values
in this early part of the record here so
here I would say there's not great
agreement between these two things we
published an article on this about
missing energy whoops and in 2010 and
both of these records the series record
the ocean heat content records have been
revised and they've found about 20%
they've in other words they both come
together a little bit I think they still
have to come together a little bit more
but this is sort of the state of the art
in terms of the energy imbalance so
there's not great agreement
between these at times there are some
marked discrepancies and his the I don't
have time to do this so anyway this is
the record for the last 1970 on showing
El Nino events in La Nina events showing
this these drops that occur following
the El Nino events and you know here's
the big big one here and because of the
more consistent La Nina events in recent
times it relates to this Pacific decadal
oscillation and I don't have time to go
into this but the Pacific decadal
oscillation has been defined based upon
analysis of sea surface temperatures
departures from the global mean in this
region here and then projected onto the
globe it looks like this and this is the
time series associated with it so the
time series annual values looks like
this and so we can define then the
positive and negative phases of the
Pacific decadal oscillation and this
negative phase here is the phase which
you have blamed on aerosols but which
I'm going to blame on the Pacific
decadal oscillation alright and and here
we're in the negative phase here and so
if we simply take this period here after
1998 and compare it with this period
through here and look at a few
quantities this is the difference now
for this period the so-called hiatus
period versus the previous period here
and it looks like this these are total
values this is using actually the guess
the NASA record and so you can see
massive warming over land and in most
places but cooling all throughout the
central and eastern Pacific so the place
that has not warmed is this region here
in the central and eastern Pacific and
over the Southern Oceans by the way this
is the change the same sort of thing in
terms of sea level pressure which is the
colors these are high pressure systems
and then low pressure systems big low
pressure system here extending up to
here and down and through here
and so if you look at this there's
low-pressure here there's a wave train
actually right down through here and
then these are the wind anomalies going
on here and this is one meter per second
and for such long periods these are very
large wind anomalies and so there's
especially strong trade winds in the
Pacific that are piling up water over in
the western part of the Pacific here you
know for this period 1999 to 2012
extending well down into the subtropics
and then there's this wave train
structure down in here this is this
low-pressure system here this is the
region where the biggest increase in
Antarctic sea ice has occurred and its
associated with this these these winds
and there's been a huge loss in
Antarctic sea ice in the Antarctic
Peninsula and so this actually accounts
for part of that pattern and then
there's a spectacular pattern going up
to the north and I want to look at that
from the northern northern North Pole
perspective to see what that looks like
and I would suggest to you that there's
actually a wave train across the pole
and the pole of course is where so his
higher pressure anti cyclonic conditions
a lot less Arctic sea ice maybe some
feedback effects but this thing has
extended a cross into into Europe and
this is the region where they've had
some very cold winters in recent times
in association with this pressure
gradient here which is the negative
phase of the North Atlantic Oscillation
so this is mainly occurring in winter
time and so there's some structure that
we can actually relate in a wave train
structure back to what's going on in the
Pacific in association with this Pacific
decadal oscillation if we look at the
ocean heat content this is the top 100
meters we see this pattern in a very
striking fashion down to 700 meters the
contours have doubled here and doubled
again here this is down to the bottom of
the ocean and so there's extra heat
going on in here mainly in the top 3 to
400 meters of the ocean where this
pattern is occurring so this has got a
lot of resilience attached to it now
thermal capacity if you like and and
the main increase below 700 meters is in
the Atlantic and over the Southern
Oceans as it turns out for the whole
ocean now it's quite dense as a this
about 3,200 Argo floats out there but
prior to 2004 there weren't pattern they
go down to 2000 meters so there's
nothing much below 2,000 meters anyway
mainly 2,000 meters yeah the I could do
town to 2,000 meters you wouldn't notice
any difference this is the changes in
sea level over the period you know sea
level altimeter
Alto metric measurements started in 1993
and if we blow up the Pacific here this
is what it looks like in the Pacific
here the rate of sea level rise is over
10 millimeters per year over 8 inches
over the 20 years that that's been going
on and here's the Philippines here so I
can't resist putting high n in here
going right over this very high sea
level extremely warm water so that even
as the the the typhoon turns up the
water it gains more warm water from
below in an exceptional fashion which is
also related to the specific decadal
oscillation so climate sensitivity
here's the formula you've seen this
before
I wanted to highlight especially the
work from auto at L where they came up
with a number of what a central value of
2.0 but if you use our or us for heat
content values this number here changes
and the climate sensitivity immediately
jumps from 2 to 2.5 and if you use other
numbers for these things such as 3.75 I
think that was also Steve's number I
don't know why they use 3.44 and
different numbers for delta T you can
easily crank this number up to 2.9 so
put a big cross over that and it's
very sensitive to which ocean heat
content values they use so that's that's
most mostly it you know this is the
summary here of of the the the fact that
there's identifiable volcanic signals
now that we can identify the ocean is
warmed in unprecedented rate in the last
decade or so at the time when there's a
hiatus and surface temperatures there's
a lesson there and about 30 percent of
that warming is below 700 meters it's
very much related to the changes in the
winds the specific decay tall
oscillation pattern the Earth's energy
imbalance varies from day to day with
clouds and weather at varies from year
to year with then so it has sharp drops
with volcanic eruptions it varies with
the Pacific decadal oscillation and
during the pause of the phase of the PDO
more heat is deposited at shallow depths
from 1976 to 1998 which is when the main
warming that we've seen has been
manifested while in the negative PDO
phase more heat is deposited below 700
meters depth and it's not then as a
parent at the surface it doesn't mean
that the planet isn't warming and so for
the 2000s you know it went from order 1
watt per square meter to about point 7
and the quiet Sun played a role from you
know 2003 to 2009 and minor volcanic
activity but the certainly evidence that
the planet is warming and it's doing all
these these things and so this is the
thing related to climate sensitivity but
all of these other things can play
greater or lesser roles as time goes on
so this is the thing that worries me
more about climate sensitivity you know
what about all of these other things and
the kinds of things that I'm talking
about here thanks